Et le petit dernier,
pas mal hein !
J'ai un peu la tête dans le pâté,
ou plutôt dans les pâtés.
Bon, d'accord, ce n'est pas moi qui
les ai confectionnés, mais croyez moi,
ça n'a pas été simple de réunir
tout ce beau monde.
Et puis, comme on dit,
l'important, c'est de participer.
Et là où je sens que l'on va avoir besoin de moi,
c'est pour vous raconter l'histoire
extraordinaire de ce plat que je n'ose pas
nommer tellement son nom fait polémique.
Alors, qu'est ce qui se cache derrière
cette chose ?
Aujourd'hui, on va briser la carapace
ou plutôt casser la croûte.
On l'avait un peu rangé au placard,
ce plat typiquement français
est en train de faire son grand retour.
Il devient même tendance.
Alors de quoi s'agit il exactement?
D'une pâte faite de farine,
de beurre, d'eau, de sel.
Certains y ajoutent même des oeufs,
mais rien d'obligatoire.
La pâte est déposée dans un moule
traditionnellement rectangulaire
et à l'intérieur de la pâte,
on va faire cuire une farce
constituée de plusieurs viandes,
plus ou moins haché,
avec des épices et des herbes,
selon votre goût.
Une fois l'ensemble cuit,
on mange tout.
Bon, ça, c'est aujourd'hui,
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas.
Suivez-moi.
Ce plat apparaît au Moyen Âge,
à cette époque
celles et ceux qui le préparent
n'utilisent pas de récipients.
C'est la pâte qui,
une fois façonnée,
fait office de contenants.
Et ce sont les pâtissiers qui
s'en chargent parce qu'ils disposent
d'un bon four
et qu'ils savent faire la pâte.
Elle est très épaisse
pour éviter à la viande de brûler
et une fois cuite,
elle forme une croûte
qui permet de conserver la farce.
Elle est si épaisse
qu'elle ne se mange pas.
On la brise,
on la met de côté
et on déguste
ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
Bon, tu vas le dire,
oui ou non ?
Pâté en croûte,
c'est pas un gros mot quand même.
Aïe! J'en vois qui fronce les sourcils.
Il est là, le problème.
Même les grands chefs
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord.
C'est un peu comme l'histoire du pain au chocolat
et de la chocolatine.
Étymologiquement, l'appellation pâté en croûte
est même un pléonasme,
car le pâté, c'est la pâte.
Dans son livre
"Mots de table, mots de bouche,"
Claudine Brécourt Villarceaux
rappelle que pâté
est un dérivé de pâtes
utilisé dès le 12e siècle.
Il est d'abord appliqué
à une pâtisserie,
à une pâtisserie, puis,
par extension, à partir du 16e siècle,
à une charcuterie
enveloppée dans une croûte.
Autrement dit, le pâté,
c'est la pâte,
c'est l'ensemble, la croûte.
Bon bah alors,
qu'est-ce qu'on dit ?
Eh bien, si on s'en tient
à la lettre,
on devrait dire paté.
Mais ce terme ayant été étendu
à d'autres charcuteries
et qu'il faut bien distinguer celle-ci,
si particulière des autres,
eh bien on parle, même si
ça heurte certaines oreilles
de pâté en croûte, pâté croûte
dans la région lyonnaise.
C'est une farce, non?
La farce, je l'ai dit,
se trouve à l'intérieur.
D'ailleurs, en ce qui concerne la farce,
chaque région quasiment à sa recette.
On peut citer le pâté lorrain
à base de porc et de veau,
le pâté de Chartres avec du perdreau,
du faisan et du foie gras
que l'on retrouve aussi
dans le pâté en croûte Richelieu.
Une bonne idée dans tous
les sens du terme que l'on doit,
selon la légende,
au cardinal du même nom.
Dans le pâté de Pâques,
on met un œuf.
Mais quoi qu'il en soit,
pour mériter son nom,
le pâté en croûte doit contenir
au moins une moitié de viande.
Mais le plus audacieux, c'est celui là :
l'oreiller de la belle Aurore.
Plus de quinze viandes différentes
pour un poids total avoisinant les 15 kg.
C'est vrai qu'après avoir mangé tout ça,
on a envie de se mettre la tête sous l'oreiller
et de ne pas se réveiller avant l'aurore.
Pas du tout.
C'est un hommage à la mère
d'Anselme Brillat-Savarin.
C'est un personnage que
tous les gastronomes connaissent.
Il a donné son nom
à un délicieux fromage.
Il était magistrat mais
il aimait aussi la bonne table.
En 1825, à la fin de sa vie,
il a rédigé un ouvrage
qui fait référence auprès
de tous les amateurs de cuisine :
La physiologie du goût.
Sa mère, baptisée Aurore, semble être
à l'origine de ce pâté si particulier.
Du coup, ça va réveiller
les papilles, ces histoires.
Un peu de patience, car en général,
l'oreiller de la belle Aurorese déguste à l'automne.
Il y a encore quelques années,
le pâté en croûte ne faisait plus recette,
on le trouvait fade, disgracieux,
totalement démodé.
Euu pardon Jamy ?!
Qui est démodé ?
Oh ! Salut Jean Croûte !
Pardon, je ne voulais pas te vexer.
Jean Croûte, c'est la mascotte officielle
du pâté en croûte.
Et il a raison de s'offusquer car aujourd'hui,
le pâté en croûte, ça ressemble plutôt à ça ou à ça.
Des pièces uniques qui font
penser à des oeuvres d'art.
En 2009, plusieurs chefs décide
de le remettre au goût du jour.
Il crée "La confrérie du pâté en croûte"
et organise même un championnat du monde.
Professionnels et amateurs venus
du monde entier s'y affrontent chaque année.
En dix ans, c'est devenu une véritable
institution et c'est très sérieux.
Les réalisations sont toutes
plus inventives que les autres.
Les viandes peuvent être marinées dans du cognac,
de l'armagnac, d'une marque de champagne ou de bourgogne.
La farce contient des champignons,
des pistaches,
la gelée comblent les vides quant à la pâte,
elle est soit brisée, soit feuilletée.
Toutes ces caractéristiques
sont minutieusement scruté par le jury.
Ils évaluent la pièce entière
mais aussi les tranches.
Une fois qu'elles sont coupées,
la cuisson, la farce, bien sûr.
L'équilibre de l'ensemble.
C'est si beau et si photogénique que le pâté en croûte
est devenu une star d'Instagram.
Alors, il a beaucoup de followers
le pâté en croûte ?
Il a surtout des milliers de like.
Sa notoriété a même
dépassé les frontières.
En 2019, c'est un chef japonais qui a remporté
le titre de champion du monde du pâté en croûte.
Et deux ans plus tôt, en 2017, devinez
ce qu'il y avait au menu du dîner de gala
entre Emmanuel Macron et l'ancien président américain
Donald Trump, en visite à Paris ?
Du pâté en croûte,
croûte que croûte.
S'il a tant de succès aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'il s'agit d'un mets raffiné et contemporain
qui met en avant les produits du terroir français.
Bref, il envoie du pâté et c'est pas
Jean Croûte qui dira le contraire.
Depuis que la peluche est commercialisée,
il s'en vend des centaines au bras.
C'est vrai que j'ai eu un petit succès !
On est loin de la banqueroute.
Ah ah ah, t'as compris ?
Allez, salut les Épicurieux.
Salut Jean Croûte !
Quant à nous, on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo.
D'ici là, n'hésitez pas à me donner en commentaire
votre recette préférée du pâté en croûte.
Et bien sûr, abonnez-vous.
Salut !